I WILL NEVER UNDERSTAND WHY THE
SURFBOARDS KEEP FALLING DOWN IN
THE OPENING SCENE THERE.
YOU ARE HERE FOR ANOTHER REASON.
>> YES, I AM.
>> FIRST ON CNN A NEW STUDY
FOUND PEOPLE WHO EXPERIENCED
EXTREME HEAT ALSO REPORTED A
DECREASE IN THEIR SENSE OF
WELL-BEING.
ACCORDING TO GALLUP IN 2020 THE
GLOBAL POPULATION FACED THREE
TIMES AS MANY EXTREME HEAT DAYS
THAN IT DID IN THE LAST 12 YEARS
AND WELL-BEING DROPPED BY NEARLY
7% DURING THAT SAME TIME YEAR.
THE RESEARCH DIRECTOR FOR THIS
PROJECT TOLD CNN, QUOTE, WHAT
WE'VE OBSERVED IN THE LAST
DECADE IS THAT THERE IS A CLEAR
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE DECLINE
IN WELL-BEING AND THOSE HIGH
TEMPERATURE DAYS AND WE ARE
PROJECT THAT GO THIS COULD
EXACERBATE IN THE FUTURE.
HERE NOW AGAIN DAYDREAM BELIEVER
AND CLIMATE CORRESPONDENT BILL
WEIR.
>> SO THIS IS REALLY AN
INTERESTING WAY TO LOOK AT
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE WORLD.
YESTERDAY WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
SEA LEVEL RISE GOING UP, ALWAYS
TALKING ABOUT TEMPERATURE GOING
UP, THIS IS THE CORRESPONDING
WELLNESS AS HUMANS WE HAVE GOING
DOWN AT THE SAME TIME AS A
RESULT OF THIS.
GALLUP IS JUST STUNNING, THIS IS
NOT SOME 2,000 PEOPLE POLL THAT
THEY PUT TOGETHER.
15 YEARS, ALMOST 2 MILLION
PEOPLE IN 170 COUNTRIES AND THEY
LOOKED AT THEIR WELLNESS SCORES
AND THAT'S BASED ON FIVE
PILLARS, HOW GOOD YOU FEEL ABOUT
YOURSELF PHYSICALLY, YOUR
RELATIONSHIPS, YOUR CAREER,
FINANCIALLY, YOUR COMMUNITY AND
THEY SAW ABOUT A HALF POINT DROP
FOR EVERY DAY WHERE THE
TEMPERATURE WAS ABOVE PRE
INDUSTRIAL AVERAGES IN THE
GLOBAL SOUTH, GULF COAST OF
MISSISSIPPI OR HOT TROPICAL
BELTS OF CHINA THE SCORES WERE
MUCH HIGHER.
YOU CAN SEE THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS THAT THE CLIMATE CRISIS
IS SO UNFAIR, AFFECTS AT LEAST
IN THIS CASE THE ELDERLY MORE
SO --
>> SEEMS TO HAVE GREATER IMPACT
ON OLDER GENERATIONS.
>> YOU CAN SEE WHY.
IT'S NOT AN OP CIVIL MISERABLE
DAY IF YOU ARE JUST STRUGGLING
TO GET THROUGH IT ON A GOOD DAY,
YOU CAN UNDERSTAND HOW THAT
MOUNTS UP AS WELL.
THERE'S ALL THE KNOCK OFF
EFFECTS, THERE IS THE STRESS AND
THE FEAR.
THEY LOOKED AT VIETNAM OVER A
ONE YEAR OF DROUGHT WELLNESS
SCORES FELL BY 11%.
THIS IS SOMETHING GALLUP HOPES
THAT LAWMAKERS AND POLICYMAKERS
LOOK AT.
IT'S NOT JUST MEASURING PHYSICAL
CHANGES IN RAINFALL PATTERNS,
IT'S HUMAN HEALTH, IT'S WELLNESS
AND STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT WHEN
IT GETS HOTTER HIGH VENT CRIME
GOES UP, BAR FIGHTS GO UP, P SAT
SCORES GO DOWN AND SO ALL OF THE
BAD STUFF ABOUT BEING HUMAN IS
EXACERBATED BY T